はぁぁ
の強みラン聞こえねえカッター
何もキモイ d なんて
今ここは音楽が無いじゃんよ
夢ここが知り金の
こんなことも写真はなりません
でも私はこのお茶内政官から見えてくるもの
楽しんりねっ
中学校4年で忍者聞こえなくなりん
ここ2年生でんした指にも聞こえ中にがいたん
領民朋と虫めんって20年
いなー締め方へてる声オオキタヌナがイメチェン
みなさんに私の声は届いていいですか
安全件
みーしゃん人と人とのコミュニケーションを楽しんでいますか
私えん五里も大事でもくん旧社紋を楽しんリンガー
もし皆さんがいた人違うてきたなぁ
true きたーーーー
大襲撃し館企画願いではないでしょうか
樹脂のコミュニケーションは
オム制御保険
旬
出演
空海に解体に
音声認識の羽生誘致キャンペーンりん
串にぴて家を読み取ってに入っ
プレでねー
さんの症状
例えば眉毛の上げ下げに刑務旬
命を聞くに支援アイン細みたいに
ん
大淀きて県切り抜くダンケたっ
入れる同署や動き1
呼吸寝る全部で15種類以上もあると思いな
持っているかもしれません
これだけたくさんあるとのコミュニケーションもワクワクといいと思いませんか
温泉キャディ neo 6人じゃ売れねえンって自由やんぐっ
はた記者に聞く五年前
でもきっと皆さんよりもコミュニケーションを楽しんでいますよねっ
ですねムッシュ支えられない相手の目を見ない
私にとってのコミュニケーションがすべてん
目で唱えていいのレッ
いることに大勢死ぬ
目と目が走ることから
種類計がー
はじめにねぇ
私は自分のコミュニケーションを
対話と呼んでいます
体目とはもともと等
2人の人が見キャンって
話をするオレだけのいいねいっ
でも私にとっぺぬ対話は少し違い年
ラズ女トレーナーせ
お願いの思いや価値観を
ことだ縁店を継ぐことで
を者以外の言葉が引き合い
他で呼ばれるを模様中じゃイン
自分そして相手を
親愛する
な一打以外をつくっていこうと
これがまた進化っていうの大までいっ
向き合って話を振るだけであげて
id 3点
強いしいない還元を
家ピンクこの剛滑りなんで
写真撮ってん昇格を失うとが
耳に聞いてん声でアナという会話の手段
失い失うことと
人とのつながりも失うということでしたっ
また週一超えていたいように
北海どんどんふむで貫通決めるん
ダメですねぇ
作っても
作って6
指の間から
ているところよして冬に
思うんでも
ジョゼーモータ用
[音楽]
祝詞ですうん
茂木目地だ
リューシーの私の音まえお
でも絵も
皆さん
想像してみてください
ジルーね前元
夢でも聞こえないんでん
まじシェ者に変えも
会員論夢でも
聞くことはできないんですっ
まにゃ桃
みんなが
私は樹若菜年
示しているよ
面白い
聞こえぬ
誰も信じられないん
いや自分が行く9
猫されたいな
音失った自分
クリーム
けどそう
釣れんかいっ
くれることは出来ない詐欺師さん
みたいにず海の底に
1人消し炭ね
静かな
キャン回目
どこかな感じきぶちゃ想いよ
文字にしてん
かことにしました
9チェーン
私に収益の時の
の人生と
enjoy いうした
生活の距離
心根陰るモヤモヤ件
お互いにできない想いよ
回ディメンター
ロンリコちょうかいても受け止めて返事を書いてくれ郡山健康堂
人間
蔵重にくいし簡単
方向に社員がいても
日中けっことで
文字に視点からコートを続けていきました
ん
もししゃっ分繋がタイムだしていたので
アイゼンっていることを心配
釣れねーでい
新辞典
雇用もいぎゃんいいマン私件
グリーム楽しくチャイはおっしゃいと繋がりたいと思う
全然ぐ
したい
家に変換
信じたん
ここを所有しちゃうとう
私は大学に入って初めて自分以外の中核障害者とで9
落ち年世界でもコミュニケーションができることを知らないだ
そしてん誰もが一緒に楽しみための海来春 d 大空間方を
しいっ
それをライフワークとしてん
結婚
出船
子連れても20円
機種代ネックついたところで
今でな聞こえ甚平を楽しんでいる私ですが
って
その私にも
聞こえで1点
ウォッチグッズ
白いキャリイ面
ピーマン
子供がメイド金
上初めて泣いた時ん
梅木初めてんわー貯金
目で初めてん
web ジャズキー
私を姫だ言ってん
お外ん
3分で行け年
決めてなその声をし翌年て時代にヒョンビン
一瞬水9一平
動いになっ
私は
ゆっ提起し日ん
その声を
チェーン新田ハンジと言いましたん
私の文様チェーン進言した好きなきゃっっ
じゃけん今も私は前新田
さやをしたいと思ってい
社名マン日本に初めて
補助のない世界で言葉の壁を越えてんカブ支部
エンターイング
ダイヤルビーに入れんぐらん会社になりだ
おとう社団クルー特別なヘッドジェット9件
祝絵にしても聞こえないでも
第5分人を
ことでもこれも
一瞬いっ
を java も使わずにん
顔無症状やんウリラーゲージで対話をテロでいっ
一声に美祢線がー
落ち願い世間件対岸すると
ブレイズ6年件
その空間 i 9というのが私と同じん
賞各賞が病む人たちで
歴史やん
さあ現元件
1万人のお客様を見てきましたん
私が客様のミントの菊サメも私を
3面
私件ウェーブゾーンを聞き急いでも応援できるねっ
歴史が姿勢も移動させると客車7をネジものを見落とし目
私がボディランゲージデー
鍛えると
聞く聖なるも一緒についててくれない
おねえ住民機プラモ悪い language 勉氏太極英語と水後で
最初は
緊張して一変
返礼が片側たため停車とかん
6少女だった人たちがー
年這わせることで148厘
部屋の利点芦屋なるんだよっ
ゆいない置き型できることを身体が思い出したように指定
はいだぜんぷでん
さあでくれるようになるので
もう遺書もや資源話前回はとね重みっ
こちらわー
私がを問う指摘する武器の
日記0
周辺件
重エンカンたっ
同会同感
聞こえリーヴィねぇねぇにっ
このことだろう何度も何度もペンディング
ん
菊井被災ね分
園庭も話ができる
聞く自在言い分
ends リーム
違いん
聞こえんかキャン聞こえないなぁ大和の
無しってはない今出張はないのでっ
マイ巡目と命令を見せて
これ以外の六園駅買おう
この場合西店
全身年期待のことでー
主良い信頼関係を
作っチェーン9プロセスするジェネのレッ
7歌い変化していっ
小中もっと対話を重ねていっちゃいとをはにもより
今日は弱者への人が集まって件
これが皆線
始めたいろんな人と
名は4月解散
ウツボ科の外来がにゃん
大字内橋前頭
明暗はしますか
ね大雨雷塗った
me
r